all right sorry that last one was
terrible here is a redo of
my firefox add-ons tutorial
um
if you want to add on to firefox first
of all i will type into firefox firefox
add-ons
and first one will be
add-ons.mozilla.org
uh where you can fashion your firefox
with whatever add-ons you might like um
slaw just i'll just pick any random one
that if it is green you can add it to
your current version of firefox if it is
grayed out then your version of firefox
is too new for them
all you have to do is click on add to
firefox button
and you will get a little window that
says are you sure you want to install
this and i say install now
it first needs to download it
second you restart firefox
and sure enough
when firefox restarts you will have
it so um i guess this is
a little
add-on notice from the add-on i just
downloaded
sure enough one new add-on has been
installed
which is
the downloadable the max downloader for
firefox max concurrent downloads these
are all the options for when i just
downloaded that is how you download an
add-on
now say you downloaded a theme
and you don't like that theme i would go
to tool uh to
tools again go to add-ons
pick the add-on that you know you don't
like anymore click on it and hit
uninstall it's really simple hit
uninstall and restart firefox
it will be gone just like that out of
your hard drive out of your system
and there are a lot of cool add-ons for
firefox like i did in one of my previous
videos this is just an uh a tutorial on
how to install and uninstall them and
that is it
uh tools add-ons
find updates this will check for updates
for any of them no updates were found
big deal
i've got a few decent add-ons i did uh
uh you know i did a uh
a video before on which ones i have
so
it's it's pretty simple uh
not really much to say about what there
are on firefox add-ons
um this is just one of them called pick
lens it's just this
uh it's pretty cool search app i should
probably do a review on this
but
um i'll get back to it you know it's
that's basically it for adding things to
your firefox web browser if you have any
requests for a tutorial or you would
like to see how to do something
uh hit me up with a
an email or a personal message and i'll
try to do an hd tutorial for you thanks
for watching guys peace